I think to try and compare what Hitler
and the Nazis did the millions of people
who died the Holocaust to the free
democracies of Europe coming together to
trade and to cooperate and in the
process to help secure peace on the
continent of Europe is frankly deeply
offensive he does say they used very
different methods he's talking about the
creation of a super-state well this is
not the creation of a super-state the
fact is the nations of Europe after the
horror of the Second World War decided
by binding their economies together in
the words of the Schumann declaration to
make a return to conflict materially
impossible and unthinkable and it has
succeeded in doing that now we're in a
site of different places the UK because
we're not part of the euro the last
Labour government quite rightly decided
that we wouldn't join and that was a
very wise decision and we're not part of
the Schengen free passport arrangement
so there are there are different views
about how Europe develops but that's
demonstrated that we are a strong and
influential country in the European
Union and we're not locked in the boot
of anybody's car not first politician to
use Hitler's name in this EU referendum
campaign Ken Livingstone of course has
been suspended for his comments do you
think the Labour reacted quickly enough
and fairly in his case what ken has been
suspended Jeremy Corbyn has set up an
inquiry into the problem of
anti-semitism in the labour party that
chamois chakrabarti is heading we're
absolutely determined to stamp it out a
very small number of members but there's
no place for it in labor even in the
mail on Sunday today you're appealing to
older voters you put that pitch across
as a grandfather you say how worried are
you about that older age group but
they're more likely to vote than other
age groups but they're also more likely
to vote for a brexit according to the
polls well that is what the polls
indicate you're right and my argument is
this this vote this decision we're going
to make is really about the future for
our children and our grandchildren it's
not about what's happened in the past
the fact is that by cooperating together
the countries of Europe have been able
to bring peace and prosperity Britain
remains a very strong and influential
country and we should think about the
change we've seen in our own lives and
the change that our children our
grandchildren will experience in theirs
and what we need to do is to make sure
that we have the means to manage it and
Europe is one of the important means
that we have got whether it's tackling
climate change dealing with flows of
refugees making sure our economies
continue to be strong based on
prosperity the economic arguments for
leaving the European Union well that is
simply not there and the leaf campaign
are really struggling on that front
because all of the warnings we've had
the governor of the Bank of England
again today making the point we will be
worse off if we leave the European Union
they would dispute that as you know and
they would cite their own economist but
on this issue of Europe keeping the
peace do you honestly think that if we
were to leave the European Union peace
and security would be at risk I think it
would make it harder to deal with the
threats we face in let's take a very
practical example Russia when Russia in
effect invaded Ukraine the countries of
Europe came together and imposed
sanctions on Russia those sanctions are
hurting President Putin would love
nothing more than to see Britain leave
the European Union because he would
think well that will make us Russia
stronger and Europe weaker and I would
secondly say this I think we have a
responsibility to honor the vision and
the leadership of those that post-war
generation of politicians because we
take the piece that we have enjoyed in
in Europe since the end of the Second
World War very much for granted because
it's all that we've experienced in our
lives but you look back you look at you
visit the graveyards of the first and
second world war and see the flower of
two generations of young Europeans who
gave their lives in conflict and it's
really important that the means by which
coming together to cooperate and trade
and talk not always to agree but it's so
much better than what went before and of
course the brexit ears would say its
NATO that matters and later won't fall
apart if if the UK pulls out of the EU
it's both you see part of the problem
with this referendum debate is that all
the ills on the part of the leave
campaign are put on the european union
and they say we should be trading with
the rest of the world we're trading with
both it is not a competition between the
two but our membership of the year
in union means that Britain has a more
powerful voice in the world it also
helps to ensure our security some people
have said that this is Labour's
referendum to lose you've got the Tories
divided over the issue of Europe are you
satisfied that the party is taking the
leadership it should on the remain vote
I am indeed because every sinew every
part of the labor movement Jeremy the
whole of the Shadow Cabinet the vast
majority of the PLP all of the major
unions party members we are out there
campaigning taking a distinct labour
message because one of the reasons we're
arguing for remain is the protection of
workers rights paid holiday limits on
working time improvements in maternity
and paternity leave now there's a
guaranteed from John O'Groats to the
peloponnese and from Lisbon all the way
to Riga if we were to leave the European
Union all of the future of all of those
would depend on a Conservative
government some would say that the
workers wages might be affected by more
immigrants coming in from the EU but
let's leave that aside for the moment
and let's just talk about how this
campaign is being played out by Labour
Jeremy called was going on holiday just
before the vote does that show real
commitment to the cause you're going to
see and hear a lot from Jeremy during
the course of the campaign he's already
shown really strong leadership with the
speeches he's made the interventions
that he's LED and his story is one of
the Labour story it's a journey from an
era when we were not in favour of
remaining in the nen Kham Common Market
41 years ago and I think it has great
force because he says I've been on that
journey and I now understand as we do as
at the party in a movement the remaining
in the European Union is best for the
British people and a step into
uncertainty will be bad for the country
its future and the future of our
children we need to think about the
agenda you taken as well of course
because you need you will pro out in
1975 but what about the queasiness about
sharing a stage with the Conservatives
jeremy corbyn who said he doesn't want
to share a stage with the Prime Minister
but doesn't this if this is such an
important decision doesn't it take that
United push to get the vote to go your
way what what is united is the view that
we should remain in but we do have
different arguments now it's known that
that if it David
if he could would have tried to we can
work a protection in the European una
that's been the history look at chris
gray what are you worried about you
worried about being associated with the
Conservatives and the Scottish
referendum clearly labour did badly and
if you're worried about that the local
elections the Scottish elections have
been and gone so what are you worried
about it's not question about being
worried about anything we have a
distinct labour message that we are
taking to labour voters and the message
is very simply this it will be bad for
our economy if we leave protecting
rights improving the environment
security Britain's influence in the
world peace and prosperity and I say to
you you know if the whole of the world
could cooperate and trade and work
together in the way that the European
Union does we would have a lot more
peace progress and prosperity in the
world it seems to me that is a really
powerful argument to put to the people
of Britain and that's what the labor
movement is doing so to push that Labour
message that the left wing side of the
argument if you like who would you like
to come to the fore to help to help
battle it out we've seen John Major for
the Conservatives former prime minister
of course fighting that argument Gordon
Brown has come out this week as well who
else should come should we see Tony
Blair for example join this argument
this is such an important decision this
will affect the lives of our children
and our grandchildren particularly if it
goes the wrong way I think it will have
a really adverse effect on what happens
in the world in future put the European
Union itself under pressure Michael Gove
appears to look forward to the European
Union beginning to move apart and I
think that would be bad for all of us
it's a responsibility for every single
one of us who feel passionate about the
case for remaining need welcome Tony
people welcome all voices I'd welcome
all voices taking part in this debate
and in particular speaking to labour
voters and also the older generation who
understand actually better than anyone
else what conflict is like because
they've heard the stories from their
parents about what happened in Europe
and for centuries this was a conflict of
continent and what's been achieved in
the last 70 years is truly remarkable
and we should honor it and we should
stay in